julian edelman the super bowl
53 mvp super bowl 53 they all blend
together too the days the months the
years the super bowls blend together
especially with the patriots winning so
many of them karen gorigen the boston
herald reported recently that it's
doubtful edelman will be able to play an
entire 2021
season due to a knee injury that
drastically limited his availability in
2020 peter i i i
j
the conspiracy mike and i'm sure the
graphic is going to come up of me
smoking a cigarette and a short sleeve
dress shirt but i i feel like edelman
wants to get to tampa bay with tommy and
gronk although tom curran told us
yesterday on pftpm that edelman is much
more of a company guy than gronk and
brady but uh you know this knee
apparently an issue apparently a problem
and it just feels like the patriots in
the process of transitioning away from
one of the most important players of the
last decade
well you know mike he only played 265
snaps last year didn't play the last two
thirds of the season
uh it just feels like you know bill
belichick is never one of these guys who
uh
is very sentimental about his roster
and to bring back a 35-year-old player
who probably is only going to be able to
play
briefly
it's you know it's football's not a
sentimental game
and so i i would i'd be surprised if he
was on the patriots i just would but and
i'd also be surprised if he was on tampa
i mean at some point don't you have to
say if your tampa
you know we've we've done
a lot of favors for tom brady okay
we gave him his tight end okay and we
brought in
against a lot of public sentiment we
brought in antonio brown
okay those things
you know basically cost us money number
one and could have really backfired on
us publicity wise uh luckily they didn't
you know nothing happened with antonio
brown last year but who knows what the
future holds
and so i guess i look at this and i say
you've gotten your entire team back
you've gotten your entire team back
that's enough
it's enough it's not time to go out and
get
and i don't mean to say edelman's a
mascot or anything he's not you know he
was a great nfl receiver but i mean
enough is enough i don't see him going
to tampa
but they do have a season ticket waiting
list in tampa again for the first time
in a long time and it's all because of
tom brady and they're going to make
millions upon millions from having brady
there and they want a super bowl with
brady and if this is a guy who you just
nurse along and unleash in the
postseason maybe he makes a difference
he did on april fool's day have one of
those is it really a joke or is he
trying to tell us something april fool's
day gags where he posted a gif
of johnny depp in one of the many
pirates of the caribbean movies before
saying it was an april fool's gag but
who knows who knows take that i knew
that was coming get that off of there
we're taking a break another hour of pfd
live still to come
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports